hi I'm Sally and I'm John and today I'm
gonna be making him hot sauce for
Father's Day I'm the father
we're very big on making gifts in our
family so I'm making this habanero hot
sauce for my dad because he could just
eat a habanero pepper on its own he
really likes the spicy food I on the
other hand cannot handle spicy food so
I'm gonna make this mild green hot sauce
for myself the first time I made this
you were really excited about it it was
really good
I pretended like it was really hard to
make so that it was more special I guess
I don't know you can see today that it
wasn't that hard but the first time I
made it
we couldn't eat it together yeah you
couldn't eat it I could you can eat so
we're gonna share the sauce on what well
the reason that I don't have a taste for
spice goes back to a time when I was
like three or four and we went to a
Chinese restaurant that's totally what I
think it just burned off all my taste
buds I was eating green beans minding my
own business and then all of a sudden
there was a very spicy green bean and it
was a hot pepper your face was red your
eyes were watering you're you were
sweating we were worried for you you
know he's so hot spicy and then I
remember my cousin coming back with milk
and it's not like I haven't tried spicy
stuff since then I just have no
tolerance that's why I really like this
green sauce because I can actually taste
the flavor of the pepper without setting
my mouth on fire
and I like Navon Arab sauce and I guess
I'm used to the heat because I like the
flavor of that pepper right it's really
good and if I ate that over above the
flavor I miss just the heat if it was
not here spice no flavor yeah
[Music]
that's really good that's really good
but juice is so good oh wow
happy Father's Day thank you love you
what is wrong oh yes
[Music]
you